how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we have so much speculation right now
about Avengers in game about what's
going to happen about time-travel about
alternate realities Thanos becoming good
a greater threat coming in there's a lot
and I think that for the most part as a
fandom we pretty much believe that we're
right about these plot points for
Avengers in game specifically that the
Avengers will go back in time or two
different realities and click their own
Infinity stones and forge their own
Infinity Gauntlet but what if we are
just completely wrong what if Avengers
endgame is not what we think it's about
after all the Russo brothers did say
that they said we have no idea what's
going to happen in Avengers in game and
that it's not what we think now the
Russo brothers tell little white lies
sometimes to keep us from knowing what's
going to happen in the movies but what
if they're telling the truth
and what if Avengers endgame is actually
about the seventh Infinity stone not a
lot of people know about the seventh
Infinity stone or otherwise known as the
ego gym in the comics and that's because
it's kind of a mystery but in this video
I'll explain exactly what the 7th
Infinity stone is how it ties in with
the other Infinity stones and defeating
Thanos the greater threat that's
supposed to come and the quantum realm
quick reminder there's only a few days
left in the Infinity Gauntlet giveaway
I'm picking a new winner on February 1st
so if you'd like to enter for your
chance to win all you have to do is be
subscribed to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
in the comics there was a amny potent
bean called nemesis and nemesis
eventually got tired of her own
existence
so she willed herself to shatter into
six Infinity stones and a seventh
Infinity stone containing her
consciousness now not much is really
known about the seventh Infinity stone
or ego stone but there are two main
things that we do know one is that in
the comics the 7th Infinity stone is
hidden in an unknown realm known as the
ultraverse and two is that when the
seventh Infinity stone comes in contact
with the other Infinity stones nemesis
will be reborn so there are a few
connections here that could link nemesis
and the seventh Infinity stone to
Avengers in game one is the actual
creation of all of the Infinity
stones if you go by what Wang said in
the beginning of Avengers infinity war
the Infinity stones were created by the
Big Bang and the Big Bang gave birth to
the current universe and the comics
nemesis existed in a universe before the
current one and the shattering of
herself created the six Infinity stones
and the Big Bang now everybody in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe only mentioned
six Infinity stones but in the comics
there were actually only believed to be
six Infinity stones as well like I said
the 7th Infinity stone was actually
hidden inside of the ultraverse and
nobody knew it existed again in the
comics the ultraverse is a hidden
unknown realm does that kind of sound
familiar it sounds like the quantum
realm we already know that the quantum
realm is going to play a huge part in
avengers endgame but what if the reason
it plays such a huge role in the movie
is because it actually contains the
seventh Infinity stone inside of it
somewhere there are many characters that
could know about or discover the seventh
Infinity stone but the 7th Infinity
stone is linked to a character that
could possibly be in a vengers endgame
and that is sirs-e seer Z is an eternal
and in the comics the ego stone actually
takes possession of her the Eternals
movie has already been confirmed and is
already in development but there has
been talk about introducing one or some
of them before the movie comes out
specifically in avengers endgame so what
if the reason that ser Z or another
eternal gets introduced in avengers
endgame is because they're actually
possessed by the ego stone and this
could be the second greater threat in
the movie again the consciousness of
nemesis is in the seventh Infinity stone
and nemesis created the other Infinity
stones and the universe so nemesis must
be aware that Thanos used six of the
Infinity stones to decimate half of the
universe so perhaps the only way to
defeat Thanos is to reunite the seventh
Infinity stone the ego stone with the
other six Infinity stones and have
nemesis be reborn again the Russo
brothers said that we have no idea what
Avengers in game is really about and we
know that they draw inspiration from the
comics and the seventh Infinity stone
does tie in to all of the important
factors and leaks that have been
mentioned about Avengers in game such as
the quantum realm the Infinity stones of
course the greater threat the
eternals being introduced and the plot
of in game being nothing that we expect
and not to mention the creation of the
universe and the Infinity stones
omnipotent beings also do exist in the
MCU and Doctor Strange they mentioned
the Living Tribunal so it's only a
matter of time until we actually see
them especially since Marvel wants to go
into the cosmos so let me know what you
all think about this and the 7th
Infinity stone being introduced in
Avengers endgame let me know in the
comments down below and again don't
forget to subscribe comment and like the
video so you can enter the giveaway and
stay up to date on everything relating
to Avengers in game as always thank you
all so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]